Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website Ed Chambers would do anything for his wife, Marguerite the couple who lived in the city of Grand Rapids, Michigan,
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。埃德·钱伯斯愿意为他的妻子玛格丽特做任何事，这对住在密歇根州大急流城的夫妇，
were a teen. Together, they had provided a safe and a loving home for four children and built successful careers. But in 1972, Ed had noticed a change in Marguerite's personality. His highly intelligent and quick-witted wife became forgetful and confused. His highly intelligent and quick-witted wife became forgetful and confused. After seeking medical advice, the couple received devastating news. At 42 years old, Marguerite had Alzheimer's disease, an incurable type of dementia that destroys memory and thinking skills. Over the following years, Marguerite became frail and was unable to carry out the simplest of everyday tasks. Ed took an early retirement to help his wife, but by the early 1980s, he accepted that Marguerite needed round-the-clock care by professionals.
曾是青少年。他们共同为四个孩子提供了一个安全且充满爱的家，并建立了成功的事业。但在1972年，埃德注意到玛格丽特的性格发生了变化。他那极其聪明、机智敏锐的妻子变得健忘且困惑。他那极其聪明、机智敏锐的妻子变得健忘且困惑。在寻求医疗建议后，这对夫妇收到了毁灭性的消息。42岁的玛格丽特患上了阿尔茨海默病，这是一种无法治愈的痴呆症，会破坏记忆力和思维能力。在接下来的几年里，玛格丽特变得虚弱，无法完成最简单的日常任务。埃德提前退休来照顾妻子，但到了20世纪80年代初，他不得不接受玛格丽特需要专业人员全天候护理的事实。
Live-in care facilities around grand rapids at that time were few and far between, so Margaret's name was added to a long list of applicants. After a two-year wait, a bed became available at Alpine Manor. Situated on the outskirts of Grand Rapids and backing on to a densely wooded area, the 208 bed nursing home was only three blocks from the chamber's house. This man to Ed could visit Marguerite as often as he wanted. He couldn't believe his luck. When Ed Chambers approached the single story brick facility, he was greeted by the director
当时大急流城周边的住家护理机构寥寥无几，所以玛格丽特的名字被加到了长长的申请名单上。经过两年的等待，高山庄园（Alpine Manor）终于有了一个床位。这家拥有208个床位的疗养院坐落在大急流城的郊区，背靠一片茂密的树林，距离钱伯斯家只有三个街区。这意味着埃德可以随心所欲地探望玛格丽特。他简直不敢相信自己的运气。当埃德·钱伯斯走近这家单层砖房设施时，他受到了护理主任的迎接，
of nursing who gave him a tour. Alpine Manor was divided into four wings. Each wing had its own nursing station. The facility was very clean and the staff were polite and well-presented. In a common area, residents sat together chatting and playing games. Ed had anticipated that the nursing home would be sterile and cold, so he was delighted to see that the floors were carpeted, curtains hung from the windows, and artwork lined to the walls. Residents could visit a beauty shop, and there was a designated dining room for meals.
她带他参观了设施。高山庄园分为四个侧翼，每个侧翼都有自己的护理站。设施非常干净，员工礼貌且仪表整洁。在公共区域，住户们坐在一起聊天、玩游戏。埃德原本以为疗养院会是冰冷且毫无生气的，所以看到地板铺着地毯、窗户挂着窗帘、墙上挂着艺术品，他感到非常高兴。住户们可以去美容店，还有一个专门的餐厅供用餐。
There were even craft activities sent to social studies classes on offer. Although Ed felt a meant guilt at having to move Marguerite into Alpine Manor, its homely atmosphere helped ease some of the pain. The director of nursing reassured Ed, telling him that Alpine Manor had been assessed by the Michigan Health Department as a standout nursing home facility. By the mid-1980s, Marguerite chambers could no longer walk or talk. She spat all day in bed, often called in a ball and rocking back and forth. Ed still visited her every day.
甚至还有手工艺活动和社交学习课程。尽管埃德因为不得不把玛格丽特送进高山庄园而感到一丝内疚，但这里温馨的氛围减轻了他的一些痛苦。护理主任让埃德放心，告诉他高山庄园已被密歇根州卫生部评估为一家出色的疗养院设施。到了80年代中期，玛格丽特·钱伯斯已经无法行走或说话。她整天躺在床上，经常蜷缩成一团，来回摇晃。埃德仍然每天去看她。
The minute Marguerite heard his voice, she stopped rocking and reached her hand up for him to take. He sat beside her holding her hand and talking to her. Occasionally she would make eye contact. Ed knew that she still recognized him. Each night, Ed talked Marguerite into bed and left her to the care of the staff at Alpine Manor. 23-year-old Kathy Wood dreamed of working in healthcare. She had done voluntary work as a nursing assistant in high school and enjoyed helping people. At age 17, Kathi's career was put on hold when she became pregnant. Now that her daughter was at school, Kathi
玛格丽特一听到他的声音，就会停止摇晃，伸出手让他握住。他坐在她身边，握着她的手与她交谈。偶尔她会与他进行眼神交流。埃德知道她仍然认得他。每天晚上，埃德帮玛格丽特上床睡觉，把她交给高山庄园的员工照顾。23岁的凯西·伍德梦想在医疗保健领域工作。她在高中时曾做过护理助理的志愿者工作，并乐于助人。17岁时，凯西因怀孕而搁置了职业生涯。现在她的女儿上学了，凯西
was eager to rekindle her passion for nursing. A nursing home a few blocks away was hiring. Alpine Manor Kathi would impressed the management with her enthusiasm. She was hired as a nursing aid and started immediately. Some residents only needed minor help, such as assistance with getting dressed or showering. Others were high needs residents who required help with daily living, such as eating and drinking, bathing, and turning in bed to prevent pressure sores. Before long, Kathy came to know every resident and their specific needs.
渴望重燃她对护理的热情。几个街区外的一家疗养院正在招聘。高山庄园的凯西以她的热情给管理层留下了深刻印象。她被聘为护理助理，并立即开始工作。一些住户只需要轻微的帮助，例如穿衣或洗澡。另一些则是高需求住户，需要日常生活的帮助，如进食、饮水、洗澡以及在床上翻身以防止压疮。不久，凯西就了解了每一位住户及其具体需求。
She was a hard worker, intelligent, and easy to talk to. Before long, she became a valued member of Alpine Manor's staff. Being a night owl, Kathy gravitated towards the night shift. It was less busy than day shifts and gave her more time to socialise with her co-workers. Nursing Aids joked that Kathy was like one of the cool kids at high school, because her colleagues followed her around, hanging off every word she said. Kathy Wood wasn't used to the attention. She had struggled with her weight her entire life, reaching almost 450 pounds after the
她工作努力、聪明且易于交谈。很快，她成为了高山庄园员工中重要的一员。作为一个夜猫子，凯西倾向于夜班。夜班比白班忙碌程度低，让她有更多时间与同事社交。护理助理们开玩笑说，凯西就像高中里那些酷孩子之一，因为她的同事们总是围着她，对她说的每一句话都言听计从。凯西·伍德不习惯这种关注。她一生都在与体重作斗争，在女儿出生后体重达到了近450磅。
birth of her daughter. As a result, she spent most of her married life indoors, fearful of the judgement of strangers. But at Alpine Manor, Kathy was showered with compliments. She began taking double shifts just to spend more time with her colleagues. Over the following months, Kathy's husband Ken watched as she changed before his eyes. Most of Kathy's days off were spent socializing with our fine manners staff. She never used to drink alcohol, but returned home from these get-togethers drunk and high on cannabis. The ones dedicated stay-at-home wife and mother now had a little interest
因此，她大部分婚后生活都在室内度过，害怕陌生人的评判。但在高山庄园，凯西受到了赞美。她开始上双倍班，只是为了花更多时间与同事在一起。在接下来的几个月里，凯西的丈夫肯看着她在他眼前发生变化。凯西大部分休息日都用来与高山庄园的员工社交。她以前从不喝酒，但从这些聚会回家时却喝得酩酊大醉，还吸食大麻。曾经全心全意顾家的妻子和母亲现在对
in spending time with her daughter and fought with Ken often. When they weren't fighting, Kathy told Ken all the worker gossip. Love triangles among the nursing aids were common, as were drunken threesomes and to alter cations between love rivals. Fighting among staff members often occurred at work, while residents listened on, unable to extricate themselves from the toxic environment. As Kathy pumped Ken full of staff secrets, he often thought to himself, what the hell is going on at Alpine Manor? In September 1986, less than six months after Kathy would start working at Alpine Manor, she
花时间陪伴女儿几乎没有兴趣，并经常与肯吵架。当他们不吵架时，凯西会告诉肯所有的员工八卦。护理助理之间的三角恋很常见，醉酒后的三人行以及情敌之间的争吵也是如此。员工之间的打斗经常发生在工作场所，而住户们则在旁边听着，无法从这种有毒的环境中解脱出来。当凯西向肯灌输员工秘密时，他经常心想，高山庄园到底发生了什么？1986年9月，在凯西·伍德开始在高山庄园工作不到六个月后，她
told Ken that she had fallen in love with someone else, an 18-year-old fellow nursing aide named Dawn. After seven years of marriage, Kathy wanted a divorce. Ken believed she was going through a phase and would return to him. In the meantime, he took their daughter to live in a hotel, while Kathy remained in their family home. Without Canada home, Kathy needed help paying the bills. A staff member introduced her to a new nurse as aid at our Pinement Up, 22-year-old Gwendolyn
告诉肯她爱上了别人，一个18岁的护理助理同事，名叫道恩。结婚七年后，凯西想要离婚。肯认为她只是处于一个阶段，最终会回到他身边。在此期间，他带着女儿住进了一家酒店，而凯西则留在了他们的家中。没有肯在家里，凯西需要帮助支付账单。一名员工向她介绍了一位高山庄园的新护理助理，22岁的格温多琳·格雷厄姆，
Graham, who went by the name Gwenn. Gwenn had no previous experience in nursing, but had taken on the role as a stepping stone to become a paramedic. Alpine Manor was chronically understaffed, so like Kathy, Gwenn had been hired on the spot. Kathy and Gwenn hid it off immediately. Having recently broken up with her girlfriend, Gwen was looking for a place to stay and had jumped at the chance to move in with Kathy. Within a week of Gwen moving in, Kathy had broken up with Dawn and she and Gwen began dating.
她叫格温。格温之前没有护理经验，但把这个职位当作成为护理人员的垫脚石。高山庄园长期人手不足，所以像凯西一样，格温被当场录用。凯西和格温一拍即合。由于刚与女友分手，格温正在寻找住处，并抓住了搬去与凯西同住的机会。在格温搬进去的一周内，凯西就与道恩分手了，她和格温开始约会。
Alpine men's nursing staff were amused at the couple's appearance. Gwen was athletically built, weighing 140 lbs and was 5 foot 2 with freckles and a ginger mullet. Kathy was 6 foot tall with a large frame, blue eyes and bleached blonde hair. The staff joked that the pair completed each other. Kathy provided the brains in the relationship, while Gwen provided the brawn. Kathy and Gwen bonded over their troubled upbringings. Kathy's father had been a strict disciplinarian, often resorting to physical violence. Her mother took a back seat
高山庄园的护理人员对这对情侣的外表感到好笑。格温身材健美，体重140磅，身高5英尺2英寸，长着雀斑，留着姜黄色的鲻鱼头。凯西身高6英尺，骨架大，蓝眼睛，漂染的金发。员工们开玩笑说这对组合互补。凯西提供了关系中的大脑，而格温提供了体力。凯西和格温因她们坎坷的成长经历而结缘。凯西的父亲是一个严厉的管教者，经常诉诸身体暴力。她的母亲退居二线，
and left the care of her other children to Kathy, who was responsible for making sure they were looked after. Gwen had been the victim of child sexual abuse at the hands of her own father. She self-harmed in her teens, describing it as a way of freeing herself from the pain of her childhood. Both Kathi and Gwen knew they were carrying a lot of emotional baggage.
把照顾其他孩子的责任留给了凯西，凯西负责确保他们得到照顾。格温曾是她亲生父亲性虐待的受害者。她在十几岁时自残，称这是从童年痛苦中解脱出来的一种方式。凯西和格温都知道她们背负着沉重的心理包袱。
There was also something else they harbored. Hatred for their elderly parents. Deaths at Alpine Manor were common. On average, five to ten residents passed each month from conditions relating to old age. Flu seasons saw the death toll climb even higher. It wasn't long after Gwen Graham started that she witnessed her first death, an elderly woman named Helen who died from pneumonia.
她们还怀有另一件事：对年迈父母的仇恨。高山庄园的死亡事件很常见。平均每月有五到十名住户因年老相关疾病去世。流感季节死亡人数还会攀升。格温·格雷厄姆开始工作后不久，就目睹了她的第一次死亡，一位名叫海伦的老妇人死于肺炎。
Gwen appeared devastated at the loss, but after Helen had been transported to the funeral home, the tears stopped. Gwen told her colleagues, I couldn't stand Helen, I couldn't stand that woman, all she did was wine all the time. About a month after Gwen started working at El Pine Manor, another new nursing aid was on the night shift when a resident pressed the call button next to their bed. The room was occupied by two residents, so the nursing aid entered quietly and in the dark. As she approached the bedside, the aid could see that the resident was sound asleep.
格温在失去海伦时表现得非常悲痛，但在海伦被送往殡仪馆后，眼泪就停止了。格温告诉同事：“我受不了海伦，我受不了那个女人，她整天只会抱怨。”格温开始在高山庄园工作大约一个月后，另一名新护理助理在夜班时，一位住户按下了床边的呼叫按钮。房间里住着两名住户，所以护理助理安静地在黑暗中走了进去。当她靠近床边时，助理看到住户睡得很熟。
As she searched for the core button to see how it had been pressed on its own, the aid felt a tight grip around her ankle. She fled the room screaming, waking up Iron Man's residence. Moments later, Gwen Graham emerged from underneath the residence bed, laughing hysterically, while other raids comforted the frightened residents. Gwen played practical jokes on her fellow staff almost every night at the expense of the residents of Alpine Manor.
当她寻找呼叫按钮看它是如何自动按下时，助理感到脚踝被紧紧抓住。她尖叫着逃离了房间，惊醒了高山庄园的住户。片刻之后，格温·格雷厄姆从住户床下钻出来，歇斯底里地大笑，而其他助理则安慰受惊的住户。格温几乎每天晚上都会以高山庄园的住户为代价，对同事开恶作剧。
When coming on shift, Gwen would turn their beds around so the bottom of the bed was where the headboard should have been. When this got old, she moved a residence into different rooms to surprise and confuse nursing aids. Gwen pulled all the wire screens from the windows that backed onto the courtyard, so she could make a hasty retreat if the charge nurse was coming.
当接班时，格温会把他们的床转过来，让床尾变成床头。当这招过时后，她会把住户搬到不同的房间，以惊吓和困惑护理助理。格温拔掉了所有通向庭院的窗户上的铁丝网，这样如果护士长来了，她可以迅速撤退。
She also hid in the courtyard at night to bang on the windows and to scare staff. It also terrified the residents. Nighthouse supervisor Tish Prascott was sick of the shenanigans. She knew a lot of the trouble stamped from Kathy Wood and Gwane Graham. They used the PA system to gossip about other staff and had residents with speech impediments read announcements just to laugh at them. Tish had tried to separate the women, but they swapped shifts with other aids so they could remain working together.
她晚上还躲在庭院里敲窗户来吓唬员工。这也吓坏了住户。夜班主管蒂什·普拉斯科特对这些恶作剧感到厌烦。她知道很多麻烦都源于凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆。她们利用广播系统八卦其他员工，并让有语言障碍的住户朗读公告，只是为了嘲笑他们。蒂什曾试图将两人分开，但她们与其他助理换班，以便能继续一起工作。
Teish had resorted to sneaking up on the pair to keep her eye on them. She often found them alone in residence rooms. Teish had also heard reports of nursing aids sneaking off to spend time together in unoccupied beds. Rumors circulated that Gwen Graham had sex with an orderly in one of the residence rooms. Tish took her concerns about Kathy Wood and Gwen Graham to the director of nursing, saying,
蒂什不得不偷偷接近两人以监视她们。她经常发现她们独自在住户房间里。蒂什还听说有护理助理溜进空床位共处。有传言称格温·格雷厄姆在其中一个住户房间里与一名护工发生了性关系。蒂什将她对凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆的担忧告诉了护理主任，说，
those two were just no good for each other. She pleaded for something to be done, explaining that resident care was suffering as a result. Upper management declared that they weren't in a position to step in. Whatever the staff chose to do on their breaks was out of their control. One night, Gwen Graham came to work so drunk that she couldn't walk in a straight line. Tis press cart sent her home and reported Gwen to management, expecting she would be fired. However, Gwen was backoken by her telephone ringing. The caller identified herself as a nurse from our Pine Manor.
“这两个人在一起只会带来麻烦。”她恳求采取行动，解释说住户护理因此受到了影响。高层管理人员宣称他们无权干涉。员工在休息时间选择做什么不在他们的控制范围内。一天晚上，格温·格雷厄姆喝得醉醺醺地来上班，连直线都走不了。蒂什·普拉斯科特让她回家并向管理层报告了格温，以为她会被解雇。然而，格温被电话铃声吵醒了。打电话的人自称是高山庄园的护士。
She explained that Nancy's mother, Belle Berkhard, a resident of the facility, had declined quickly in health. Bell wasn't expected to make it through the day. Nancy lived three hours drive away from our pine manor. She couldn't afford to miss work that day, so after a long, anxious shift, she raced to her ailing mother. She hoped and prayed that she'd still be alive to say her goodbyes.
她解释说，南希的母亲，该设施的住户贝尔·伯克哈德，健康状况急剧恶化。贝尔恐怕撑不过今天了。南希住在距离高山庄园三小时车程的地方。她那天不能错过工作，所以在漫长而焦虑的轮班后，她赶往病重的母亲身边。她希望并祈祷母亲还活着，能让她告别。
Nancy arrived at Alpine Manor and rushed to Belle's room. Her bed was empty. Nancy inquired at the nursing station. None of the nurses knew where Belle Burkard was. None of the nurses knew where Belle Berkard was. They appeared bemused when Nancy told them she had received a phone call in the early hours from a nurse telling her that her mother was about to pass away. Belle Berkard was discovered sitting at a dining room table, a live, and like her normal self. Nancy fed her dinner and then stopped to talk to the charge nurse who checked the record. Nobody had logged a call to Nancy. Furthermore
南希到达高山庄园，冲进贝尔的房间。她的床是空的。南希在护理站询问。没有护士知道贝尔·伯克哈德在哪里。没有护士知道贝尔·伯克哈德在哪里。当南希告诉她们她在凌晨接到一名护士的电话，说她母亲快要去世时，她们显得很困惑。贝尔·伯克哈德被发现坐在餐厅的桌子旁，活着，像往常一样。南希喂她吃了晚饭，然后停下来与检查记录的护士长交谈。没有人记录过给南希打过电话。此外，
there were no staff notes indicating concerns for her mother's health. It became clear that Nancy had been the victim of a cruel hoax call from the night shift. The charge nurse checked who had been working that shift. One name stood out. Kathy Wood. At the end of 1986, an anonymous complaint was made to the Michigan Health Department regarding the level of care at Alpine Manor. There were reports of residents sitting in soiled incontinence aids for hours and only being bathed once a week. Staff turnover was cited as the main reason for the lack of care.
没有员工记录显示对她母亲的健康状况有任何担忧。很明显，南希是夜班员工恶作剧电话的受害者。护士长检查了谁在那个班次工作。一个名字脱颖而出：凯西·伍德。1986年底，密歇根州卫生部收到了一份关于高山庄园护理水平的匿名投诉。有报告称住户在弄脏的失禁用品中坐了几个小时，而且每周只洗一次澡。员工流动率被认为是护理缺失的主要原因。
112 nurses' aids had been hired during that year. By October, 71 had left. To quell public concern, Alpine Manor was subject to an unannounced visit from a health inspector. A lot had changed in recent years. One staff member described Alpine Manor as having an eerie atmosphere. Residents were treated like children. The craft member described Alpine Manor as having an eerie atmosphere. Residents were treated like children.
那一年雇用了112名护理助理。到10月，已有71人离职。为了平息公众担忧，高山庄园接受了卫生检查员的突击检查。近年来发生了很多变化。一名员工形容高山庄园有一种阴森的氛围。住户被当作孩子对待。那名员工形容高山庄园有一种阴森的氛围。住户被当作孩子对待。
Staff spoke to them in child-like voices and styled the female residents long hair into pigtails. The craft room now only contained children's coloring books and a few crayons. Cartoon pictures and drawings were taped to the walls. Residents reliant on wheelchairs were pushed together with nothing to keep them occupied. Meanwhile, a local radio station blasted over the PA system to drown out the screams from residents with dementia. Following the visit from the health inspector, a report was issued. It found that our pine manor was safely practicing within state guidelines.
员工用孩子气的语调与他们交谈，并将女性住户的长发扎成辫子。手工室现在只放着儿童涂色书和几支蜡笔。卡通图片和画作被贴在墙上。依赖轮椅的住户被推在一起，没有任何东西让他们打发时间。与此同时，当地广播电台通过广播系统大声播放，以掩盖痴呆症住户的尖叫声。卫生检查员访问后，发布了一份报告。报告发现高山庄园在州指导方针内安全运营。
No further follow-up was needed. Despite the ongoing issues caused during their employment, both Kathy Wood and Gwen Graham continued to receive praise from upper management. They regarded the women as extremely hard workers, both often pulled double shifts to make up for understaffing. On a competency test issued by the State Health Department, Gwen scored a 97% mark. On her test sheet, the examiner wrote the word great on every page and drew a big smiley face.
无需进一步跟进。尽管她们在受雇期间造成了持续的问题，但凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆仍然受到高层管理人员的赞扬。他们认为这两个女人工作极其努力，两人经常上双倍班以弥补人手不足。在州卫生部发布的能力测试中，格温获得了97分。在她的测试卷上，考官在每一页都写了“棒”字，并画了一个大笑脸。
They were particularly impressed with Gwen's use of washcloths. On her exam paper, Gwen wrote that she rolled them up into log shapes and put them in the palms of residents clenched hands to stop their fingernails from digging into their skin. She always carried washcloths with her, and could be seen with at least one flapping from the back pocket of her pants at all times. Cathy and Gwen had a tight friendship circle of fellow nursing aids, but there were a few staff members who saw through their charade. They regarded Kathy and Gwen as bullies and liars, who ruled through intimidation.
他们对格温使用洗脸巾的方式印象特别深刻。在她的试卷上，格温写道，她把它们卷成圆木状，放在住户紧握的手掌中，以防止他们的指甲刺入皮肤。她总是随身携带洗脸巾，随时都能看到至少一条从她裤子的后口袋里露出来。凯西和格温有一个紧密的护理助理朋友圈，但也有少数员工看穿了她们的伪装。他们认为凯西和格温是欺凌者和骗子，通过恐吓进行统治。
Kathy once complained about a fellow aid she didn't like to a superior, saying that the aid wasn't changing in continents' aides overnight. The charge nurse accompanied Kathy and found a resident lying in a puddle of urine. Later, it transpired that Kathy had asked Gwen to pour cups of water over the resident's legs to make them soaking wet. As detailed in the book Forever and Five Days by Lowell Corfield, Gwen later said, everybody was scared of Kathy, Kathy would fuck with you, that was just her thing and everybody knew it. It kind of made me feel good because she was my girl, and as long as she was my girl, nobody was going to fuck
凯西曾向一位上级抱怨她不喜欢的一位同事，称该助理没有在夜间更换失禁用品。护士长陪同凯西检查，发现一名住户躺在尿泊中。后来，事实证明凯西曾要求格温将几杯水倒在住户的腿上，使他们湿透。正如洛厄尔·科菲尔德在《永远与五天》（Forever and Five Days）一书中所述，格温后来表示：“每个人都怕凯西，凯西会整你，那是她的风格，每个人都知道。这让我感觉很好，因为她是我的女孩，只要她是我的女孩，就没人敢整我。”
with me. One morning, a nursing aide was working with Kathy to dress a particularly difficult resident. All day, he screamed and yelled, yet whenever he saw Kathy would, he quietened straight away. Nurses had previously joked about Kathy's ability to silence the man. On this occasion, the nursing aid asked Kathy how she managed to quiet him.
一天早上，一名护理助理正与凯西一起为一位特别难伺候的住户穿衣。他整天尖叫大喊，但每当他看到凯西·伍德时，他立刻就安静下来。护士们之前曾开玩笑说凯西有让男人安静下来的能力。这次，护理助理问凯西她是如何让他安静下来的。
Just watch, Kathy said. She proceeded to whisper something into the man's ear. Within seconds he became fearful and asylum. The aid asked Kathy what she had said. With a smile she replied, I said, go ahead, scream one more time. But look at me, I'm bigger than you. I'm huge in fact. You are helpless, I am not. You scream one more time and I will kill you
“看着，”凯西说。她接着在那个男人的耳边低语了一些话。几秒钟内，他变得恐惧并沉默了。助理问凯西她说了什么。她微笑着回答：“我说，继续，再尖叫一次。但看看我，我比你大。事实上，我非常巨大。你是无助的，我不是。你再尖叫一次，我就杀了你，
and there will be nothing you can do to stop me." The aide considered reporting Kathy Woods remarked to management but she was too frightened of the fallout from Kathy and Gwen and chose to keep it to herself. Nights later, a nursing aide named Ladonna was working the night shift when she answered the call button of 87-year-old Clara Pierce. Clara had been at Alpine Manor for six years and suffered from dementia. She was still quite lucid and could hold conversations with the staff. As soon as Ladona rented her room, Clara screamed, they're going to kill me.
而且你将无能为力。”助理考虑向管理层报告凯西·伍德的话，但她太害怕凯西和格温的报复，选择了保持沉默。几天后，一名叫拉多娜的护理助理在夜班时接到了87岁的克拉拉·皮尔斯的呼叫按钮。克拉拉在高山庄园住了六年，患有痴呆症。她仍然很清醒，可以与员工交谈。拉多娜一进入她的房间，克拉拉就尖叫道：“他们要杀了我。
They whisper to me that they are going to kill me. Clara had recently been found wandering the halls at night, so the doctor had ordered that her wrists be tied to the bed while she was sleeping. Ladonna released Clara and escorted her to the bathroom and back to bed. As Ladonna reapplied Clara's restraints, she begged not to be tied up, yelling, you don't understand, they're coming to kill me. Ladonna re-assured Clara that no one was coming to kill her. Ladonna turned off the light and left Clara alone, strapped to her bed. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. It's the calm before the holiday storm, but you can prepare your e-commerce business
他们低声对我说他们要杀了我。”克拉拉最近被发现晚上在走廊里徘徊，所以医生下令在她睡觉时将她的手腕绑在床上。拉多娜解开了克拉拉，护送她去洗手间并回到床上。当拉多娜重新给克拉拉系上束缚带时，她恳求不要被绑起来，大喊：“你不明白，他们要来杀我。”拉多娜安慰克拉拉说没有人会来杀她。拉多娜关掉灯，留下克拉拉一个人，被绑在床上。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。这是假日风暴前的平静，但您可以准备您的电子商务业务
for the holiday rush now just by using Shipstation. Whether you're shipping from your house or a warehouse, Shipstation can help increase your profitability. Save time automating your shipping and returns in the Shipstation dashboard and keep costs down with industry leading carrier discounts while your holiday orders roll on. And Shipstation is available in the UK, Australia and Canada. Shipstation offers effortless integration everywhere you sell online, including Amazon, Etsy, eBay, Shopify and more. Manage orders, print labels, compare rates and optimize every shipment. You can quickly
迎接假日高峰，现在只需使用Shipstation。无论您是从家里还是仓库发货，Shipstation都能帮助提高您的盈利能力。在Shipstation仪表板中自动化您的运输和退货以节省时间，并利用行业领先的承运商折扣降低成本，同时您的假日订单源源不断。Shipstation在英国、澳大利亚和加拿大均有提供。Shipstation为您在线销售的任何地方提供轻松集成，包括亚马逊、Etsy、eBay、Shopify等。管理订单、打印标签、比较费率并优化每一批货物。您可以快速
and easily update crucial order information and reduce errors. Case file team member Paulina runs a Shopify store and used Shipstations free trial before signing up. She tells me she can't imagine life without Shipstation now. One of her favorite features is having everything she needs in one simple interface. But the most important thing is she saved money, time, and hassle. And Paulina isn't the only one. 98% of companies who stick with ShipStation for a year become customers for life. Set your business up for holiday shipping success with Shipstation. Go to shipstation.com and use code
轻松更新关键订单信息并减少错误。案件档案团队成员保琳娜经营着一家Shopify商店，并在注册前使用了Shipstation的免费试用版。她告诉我，她现在无法想象没有Shipstation的生活。她最喜欢的功能之一是拥有一个简单界面所需的一切。但最重要的是，她节省了金钱、时间和麻烦。保琳娜并不是唯一一个。98%坚持使用Shipstation一年的公司成为了终身客户。用Shipstation为您的业务做好假日运输成功的准备。前往shipstation.com并使用代码
case file today and sign up for your free 60-day trial. That's shipstation.com code case file. Too busy achieving all your day-to-day goals to cook, but want to make sure you're reading well? With Factor, skip the extra trip to the grocery store and the chopping, prepping, and cleaning up too, while still getting the flavor and nutritional quality you need. Factor's fresh never throws a meal so ready in just two minutes, so all you have to do is heat and enjoy, then get back to crushing your goals. Choose from over 34 weekly
case file，立即注册您的60天免费试用。即shipstation.com代码case file。太忙于实现所有日常目标而无法做饭，但想确保自己吃得好？有了Factor，跳过额外的杂货店购物、切菜、准备和清理工作，同时仍然获得您需要的风味和营养质量。Factor的新鲜餐点从不冷冻，只需两分钟即可准备好，所以您所要做的就是加热并享用，然后回到实现您的目标中。从超过34种每周
flavor-packed dietician-approved meals and level up with gourmet plus options, prepared to perfection by chefs and ready to wait in record time. Treat yourself to upscale meals with premium ingredients like broccolini, lakes, truffle butter and asparagus. If you're looking for calorie-conscious options, Factor also offers delicious calorie smart meals with around or less than 550 calories per serving. Case file team member Atavia tells me that factor meals are like something you'd expect to eat at a fancy restaurant. Her favorite is the vegetarian green chili to start a bake with corn salsa and sour cream.
风味十足、营养师认可的餐点中进行选择，并通过由厨师精心准备、在创纪录时间内即可享用的美食升级选项提升水平。用西兰花、韭菜、松露黄油和芦笋等优质食材犒劳自己。如果您正在寻找注重卡路里的选择，Factor还提供美味的卡路里智能餐点，每份约550卡路里或更少。案件档案团队成员阿塔维亚告诉我，Factor的餐点就像您在高级餐厅吃到的东西。她最喜欢的是素食绿辣椒玉米饼配玉米莎莎酱和酸奶油。
Otavia says it makes meal planning so much easier, especially lunch. Rather than grabbing a snack or junk food, she has a proper healthy meal ready to go. Head to factormeals.com slash case file 50 and use code case file 50 to get 50% off. That's code case file 50 at factormeals.com slash case file 50 to get 50% off. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors,
阿塔维亚说这让膳食计划变得容易多了，尤其是午餐。与其吃零食或垃圾食品，她有一顿合适的健康餐点准备就绪。前往factormeals.com斜杠case file 50并使用代码case file 50即可获得50%的折扣。即代码case file 50在factormeals.com斜杠case file 50即可获得50%的折扣。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，
you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. On Christmas Day, 1986, Ed Chambers drove to Alpine Manor to visit his wife, Marguerite. He was joined by his daughter, Jen, who had some warm clothing to give her ailing mother. Marguerite's room in Alpine Manor always seemed to be cold, and Marguerite often kicked off her bedsheets with her rocking movements. Upon arriving at Alpine Manor, Jan noticed a dried food caked around her mother's mouth, indicating that she hadn't been cleaned since her last meal. Jan found a washcloth and dampened it.
您支持案件档案继续提供高质量的内容。1986年圣诞节，埃德·钱伯斯开车去高山庄园探望他的妻子玛格丽特。他的女儿简也一起来了，她带了一些保暖的衣服给病重的母亲。玛格丽特在高山庄园的房间似乎总是很冷，玛格丽特经常因为摇晃的动作踢掉床单。到达高山庄园后，简注意到母亲嘴边结了一层干掉的食物，表明她自上一顿饭以来就没有被清理过。简找了一块洗脸巾并把它弄湿。
When she went to wipe her mother's face with it, Muggeri jumped. She turned her head from side to side, refusing to have her mouth cleaned. Muggeri's Alzheimer's prevented her from speaking, so Jan couldn't ask her what was wrong. But when she looked into her mother's eyes, she saw something she would never forget. Absolute terror During the week prior, Marguerite chambers had been looked after by two nurses more than any others. Kathy Wood and Gwengram. Post Christmas, Marguerite was not herself.
当她去擦拭母亲的脸时，玛格丽特跳了起来。她左右转动头部，拒绝清理嘴巴。玛格丽特的阿尔茨海默病使她无法说话，所以简无法问她出了什么问题。但当她看着母亲的眼睛时，她看到了她永远不会忘记的东西：绝对的恐惧。在过去的一周里，玛格丽特·钱伯斯主要由两名护士照顾：凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆。圣诞节后，玛格丽特状态不对。
She was feverish and appeared to have gone downhill physically. Nobody could pinpoint why. A little under a month later, on Sunday, January 18, 1987, Ed Chambers returned to our pine manor. Marguerite made rocking movements in bed as Ed held her hand and talked to her for an hour. At 8pm, he said good night and left. Thirty minutes later, a nursing aid found Marguerite chambers unresponsive in bed. Efforts to revive her failed, and Marguerite was pronounced dead.
她发烧了，身体状况似乎急剧下降。没人能查出原因。不到一个月后，1987年1月18日星期日，埃德·钱伯斯回到高山庄园。玛格丽特在床上做着摇晃的动作，埃德握着她的手与她交谈了一个小时。晚上8点，他说了晚安并离开了。三十分钟后，一名护理助理发现玛格丽特·钱伯斯在床上没有反应。抢救无效，玛格丽特被宣布死亡。
She was 60 years old. One by one nursing staff went into Margarit's room to pay their respects. Among them were Kathy Wood and Gwen Graham. As per protocol following a death at Alpine Manor, the charge nurse phoned to the facilities on called Doctor. It was a Sunday night and he didn't want to drive through the heavy snow to examine Margaret's body in person. Instead, he ordered her to be transferred to the mortuary over the phone.
她享年60岁。护理人员一个接一个地走进玛格丽特的房间表示敬意。其中包括凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆。按照高山庄园死亡后的程序，护士长给该设施的随叫随到医生打了电话。那是星期天晚上，他不想冒着大雪亲自检查玛格丽特的尸体。相反，他在电话里下令将她转移到太平间。
The following day, the doctor signed Margaret's death certificate without having seen her body. Under the cause of death, he wrote, Hard Attack. Three weeks later, on the morning of Tuesday, February 3, a registered nurse began her shift at Elpion Manor. She soon noticed that a 95-year-old resident named Mertel Luce had blood dripping from her nose. The nurse applied a compress and made a note of the incident, but didn't think any more about it. A series of strokes and organic brain syndrome had robbed a Mertel of her normal functions.
第二天，医生在没有看到尸体的情况下签署了玛格丽特的死亡证明。在死因一栏，他写道：心脏病发作。三周后，2月3日星期二早上，一名注册护士开始在高山庄园轮班。她很快注意到一位名叫默特尔·卢斯的95岁住户鼻子在滴血。护士贴上了敷料并记录了这一事件，但没再多想。一系列中风和器质性脑综合征剥夺了默特尔的正常功能。
Although she was somewhat aware of what was going on around her, she could no longer walk or talk. Mertel spent the majority of her time curled up in bed in the fetal position. The only time Mertel seemed to know what was going on around her was when her son came to visit. When she saw him, Mertel changed instantly. She smiled and patted his face. Because of her high care needs, Kathy would openly complain to her colleagues that she didn't like Mertle loose.
虽然她对周围发生的事情有所察觉，但她已经无法行走或说话。默特尔大部分时间蜷缩在床上，呈胎儿姿势。默特尔唯一似乎知道周围发生什么的时候是她儿子来探望时。当她看到他时，默特尔立刻变了。她微笑着拍打他的脸。由于她需要高水平护理，凯西·伍德公开向同事抱怨她不喜欢默特尔·卢斯。
She found her too difficult to take care of. A week after Mertle was treated for her unexplained bloody nose, a nurse aide found her deceased in bed. This time, her nose was covered in mucus and looked bruised. On the mattress beside Mertel's body was a rolled-up washcloth. Mertel's body was sent directly to the mortuary by the up-line manned doctor without examination, as in the case of Muggery Chambers. And like that incident, the doctor listed Mertel's cause of death as heart attack.
她觉得她太难照顾了。在默特尔因不明原因流鼻血接受治疗一周后，一名护理助理发现她死在床上。这一次，她的鼻子覆盖着粘液，看起来有淤青。在默特尔尸体旁边的床垫上，有一块卷起来的洗脸巾。默特尔的尸体被高山庄园的医生直接送往太平间，没有进行检查，就像玛格丽特·钱伯斯的案例一样。和那次事件一样，医生将默特尔的死因列为心脏病发作。
Mertel's loved ones were surprised by the news of her sudden death. She had undergone a physical exam just days earlier, during which the doctor had described her heart health as impeccable. Following Mertel's funeral, her family penned a card to the Alpine Manor staff to thank them for the care and compassion they had shown Mertel while she was alive. It was pinned to the staff bulletin board. Days later, Kathy Wood and Gwen Graham invited Kathy's ex-girlfriend Dawn over to their place. As they sat in the living room drinking, Gwen casually mentioned that she had been responsible
默特尔的亲人对她突然死亡的消息感到惊讶。她几天前刚接受过体检，医生当时形容她的心脏健康状况无可挑剔。默特尔葬礼后，她的家人给高山庄园的员工写了一张卡片，感谢他们在默特尔生前给予的照顾和同情。卡片被贴在员工公告栏上。几天后，凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆邀请凯西的前女友道恩到她们家。当她们坐在客厅喝酒时，格温随口提到她对默特尔的死负责。
for Murtle's death. Gwen asked Dawn if she wanted to see proof. Dorn followed Gwan and Kathy into the bedroom. On a shelf lay a single sock. This belonged to her, Gwan said. Dorn was well aware of the twisted pranks and mind games the couple often played. She passed off the comment as a sick joke. Kathy was known to steal from the residents of our Pine Manor,
格温问道恩是否想看证据。道恩跟着格温和凯西走进卧室。架子上放着一只袜子。“这是她的，”格温说。道恩很清楚这对情侣经常玩的扭曲恶作剧和心理游戏。她把这番话当作一个恶心的玩笑。凯西以偷窃高山庄园住户的东西而闻名，
once taking a resident's rosary beads to hang from the review mirror of her truck. The more Dawn thought about it, the more she believed that the pair had just stolen a sock, or that it belonged to Kathy. Dawn told herself, Gwen's just fucking with me. On the morning of Monday, February 16, 1987, an Alpine man- nursing aid named Sean appeared into the room of 79-year-old resident Mae Mason. Mae, who had Alzheimer's disease, was awake. She fidgeted with her hands in bed and a seamed agitated.
曾拿走一位住户的念珠挂在她的卡车后视镜上。道恩越想越觉得两人只是偷了一只袜子，或者那是凯西的。道恩告诉自己：“格温只是在整我。”1987年2月16日星期一早上，高山庄园的一名护理助理肖恩窥视了79岁住户梅·梅森的房间。患有阿尔茨海默病的梅醒着。她在床上不安地摆弄着双手，显得很烦躁。
Sean took a damp washcloth to freshen Mae, wiping it over her face and hands. But this only heightened May's distress. She kept clutching at the washcloth, not wanting it to touch her skin. Sean tried to calm May but had to check on other residents. She rolled May from her side onto her back and tucked her in, pulling the covers to her neck. When she left, Mae was wide awake. Two hours later, Sean checked on Mae again. Her skin had turned grey and her fingernails were now blue. Her pulse was imperceptible and she was pronounced deceased at 4am.
肖恩拿了一块湿洗脸巾给梅擦拭，擦过她的脸和手。但这只会加剧梅的痛苦。她不停地抓着洗脸巾，不想让它碰到皮肤。肖恩试图安抚梅，但必须去检查其他住户。她把梅从侧卧翻到仰卧，并帮她盖好被子，拉到脖子处。她离开时，梅还清醒着。两小时后，肖恩再次检查梅。她的皮肤变成了灰色，指甲现在是蓝色的。她的脉搏无法察觉，她在凌晨4点被宣布死亡。
Sean was devastated and sought support from her colleagues. Fellow aid Gwen Graham did her best to comfort her. May Mason's cause of death was listed as cardiac arrest by her family physician. Her death came six days after murder lose. The next day, 74-year-old Alpine Manor resident Belle Berkhard was found to have bruising to her face, particularly around her nose and right cheek. The injuries were reported to management. As Bell often suffered from seizures, they put the injuries down to an un-witnessed seizure during the night.
肖恩悲痛欲绝，向同事寻求支持。同事格温·格雷厄姆尽力安慰她。梅·梅森的死因被她的家庭医生列为心脏骤停。她的死亡发生在默特尔·卢斯去世六天后。第二天，74岁的高山庄园住户贝尔·伯克哈德被发现脸部有淤青，特别是在鼻子和右脸颊周围。伤情已报告给管理层。由于贝尔经常癫痫发作，他们将伤情归因于夜间未被目击的癫痫发作。
It was assumed she must have hit her head on the bed's metal railings. The nurse assigned to Bell that night was Kathy Wood. She was never questioned about it and it wasn't investigated further. Kathy often complained to other staff about Belle Burkards' high-care needs. She didn't like Belle. The feeling was mutual. Belle made it difficult for Kathy to turn her, often gripping onto bedbars. Whenever Kathy tried to verbally intimidate her, Bell would just laugh in her face. At 3am on Thursday, February 26, Kathy volunteered to supervise the nurses' station while the other staff went on break.
人们认为她一定是撞到了床的金属栏杆上。那天晚上分配给贝尔的护士是凯西·伍德。她从未被质问过，也没有进行进一步调查。凯西经常向其他员工抱怨贝尔·伯克哈德的高护理需求。她不喜欢贝尔。这种感觉是相互的。贝尔让凯西很难帮她翻身，经常抓住床栏。每当凯西试图口头恐吓她时，贝尔只是对着她的脸大笑。2月26日星期四凌晨3点，凯西主动提出在其他员工休息时监督护理站。
Bell Burkhard was found deceased a few hours later. The nursing aid who found her noticed that Bell's arm was positioned at an odd angle underneath her body. When Bell's body was bathed for the funeral home, the aid noticed that the same arm was badly bruised. Nobody knew why. One of Cathy Woods' nursing friends suggested that the bruising might have been caused from the nursing aid not turning Bell during the night. The matter was dismissed. Bell was released to the mortuary without a doctor viewing her body.
贝尔·伯克哈德几小时后被发现死亡。发现她的护理助理注意到贝尔的手臂以一种奇怪的角度放在身体下方。当贝尔的尸体被送往殡仪馆清洗时，助理注意到同一只手臂有严重的淤青。没人知道原因。凯西·伍德的一位护理朋友建议，淤青可能是因为护理助理晚上没有给贝尔翻身造成的。此事被驳回。贝尔在没有医生查看尸体的情况下被送往太平间。
The cause of death was listed as a heart attack. Like Mertle loose's family, Belle Bercards couldn't believe what had happened. During a check-up a week prior, the doctor had mentioned her heart was fine. As the number of sudden deaths in Alpine Managru, Cathy Wood, Gwen Graham and their Alpine Manacohorts became increasingly out of control. The couple would host wild parties at their home on their days off, during which staff in attendance would run down the street topless. For no discernible reason, the disorderly group would get into physical fights with each
死因被列为心脏病发作。像默特尔·卢斯的家人一样，贝尔·伯克哈德的家人无法相信发生了什么。在一周前的检查中，医生曾提到她的心脏很好。随着高山庄园猝死人数的增加，凯西·伍德、格温·格雷厄姆和她们的高山庄园同伙变得越来越失控。这对情侣在休息日会在家里举办狂野派对，参加的员工会赤裸上身在街上奔跑。出于无法解释的原因，这群混乱的人会在酒吧和俱乐部里与彼此发生肢体冲突，
other at pubs and clubs, resulting in serious injuries. Nursing aid Ladonna had two of her teeth knocked out during one inexplicable altercation. In the book, Forever and Five Days, Ladonna said, we had all gone crazy, we didn't care for each other's feelings, we didn't have any feelings. One day, in April 1987, a nursing aide named Catherine snuck through the back door of our pine manner and entered the director of nursing's office. With a black eye, her arm in a sling and a cracked rib, Catherine didn't want to be seen by her colleagues as she asked for time off. Initially, brushing off her injuries as the result of an accident, the truth was soon uncovered.
导致严重受伤。护理助理拉多娜在一次莫名其妙的争吵中被打掉了两颗牙齿。在《永远与五天》一书中，拉多娜说：“我们都疯了，我们不关心彼此的感受，我们没有任何感觉。”1987年4月的一天，一名叫凯瑟琳的护理助理从高山庄园的后门溜进去，进入了护理主任的办公室。她带着黑眼圈、手臂吊着绷带、肋骨骨折，不想被同事看到，于是请求休假。起初，她将伤势轻描淡写为事故的结果，但真相很快被揭露。
Cathy Wood had to lure Catherine to a deserted area on the outskirts of Grand Rapids with the pretense of hooking up. Other nursing aids were also there, watching in amusement, as Gwen Graham confronted Catherine. She knocked her to the ground, then punched and kicked her repeatedly in the chest and stomach. Gwen was called into the office and asked if the story was true. Smiling, Gwen explained, I wouldn't do something like that.
凯西·伍德以约会为借口将凯瑟琳引诱到大急流城郊区的一个荒凉地区。其他护理助理也在场，饶有兴致地看着格温·格雷厄姆与凯瑟琳对峙。她将她打倒在地，然后反复拳打脚踢她的胸部和腹部。格温被叫到办公室，被问及故事是否属实。格温微笑着解释说：“我不会做那种事。”
She left the office and faced no repercussions. The incident had staff terrified of Cathy and Gwen, with many refusing to work with them. Reports continued to flood management about the pair's toxic behaviour. Yet, when given a report about Cathy's bullying, the Arpine Manor manager ripped it up and threw it in the bin. She was friends with Kathy and didn't want her to get into trouble. Instead, the manager decided to separate Kathy from the aides that were making the allegations against her. Kathy was called into the manager's office and was given the good news. She had been promoted. She was now in charge of nursing aids on her shift.
她离开了办公室，没有受到任何惩罚。这起事件让员工们对凯西和格温感到恐惧，许多人拒绝与她们共事。关于两人恶劣行为的报告不断涌向管理层。然而，当阿尔派恩庄园（Alpine Manor）的经理收到一份关于凯西霸凌行为的报告时，她将其撕碎并扔进了垃圾桶。她和凯西是朋友，不想让凯西惹上麻烦。相反，经理决定将凯西与那些指控她的护理员分开。凯西被叫到经理办公室，并得到了好消息：她升职了。她现在负责轮班时的护理助理。
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Many of Cathy Wood's work friends were thrilled with her promotion, but there was one who wasn't. Gwen Graham. She believed she worked harder than Cathy and she should have been the one promoted. It made things difficult at home.
案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的内容来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。凯西·伍德的许多工作伙伴对她的升职感到兴奋，但有一个人除外：格温·格雷厄姆。她认为自己比凯西工作更努力，理应是她升职。这让她们在家里的生活变得困难。
Cathy and Gwen argued often with the fights often culminating in violence. The walls of their house were damaged with holes as a result of punches thrown in fits of anger. When Cathy learned Gwen had sex with another nursing aid, she became furious, yelling so loudly that her screams were heard from down the street. When Gwen tried to leave the house, Kathy dragged her back in by her hair and slapped her repeatedly. She was often seen at work covered in scratches and bruises. By mid-1987, Gwen had had enough. She moved out of Kathy's home and into a trailer.
凯西和格温经常争吵，争吵往往以暴力告终。由于愤怒中挥出的拳头，她们房子的墙壁上布满了破洞。当凯西得知格温与另一名护理助理发生性关系时，她变得暴跳如雷，尖叫声大到街对面都能听到。当格温试图离开家时，凯西揪住她的头发把她拖了回来，并反复扇她耳光。人们经常看到她在工作中浑身是伤和淤青。到1987年中期，格温受够了。她搬出了凯西的家，住进了一辆拖车里。
Joining Gwen was her new girlfriend, a 21-year-old nursing aide from our plan manor named Heather Barraja. Heather, who had never been in a relationship before, told Gwen she was madly in love with her. Together they hatched a plan. They would leave Grand Rapids and return to Gwen's hometown in Texas to start over. Kathy found out and visited Gwen, demanding she return home. After an argument, Gwen agreed. Kathy took her to the bedroom where they had sex. As detailed in forever and five days, as Gwen lay on the bed, Kathy retrieved some restraints she had taken from our plain manner. She tied Gwen's wrists to the bed, then she walked to the foot of the bed.
和格温住在一起的是她的新女友，一名来自阿尔派恩庄园的21岁护理助理，名叫希瑟·巴拉哈。希瑟以前从未谈过恋爱，她告诉格温她疯狂地爱着她。她们一起制定了一个计划。她们要离开大急流城，回到格温在德克萨斯州的家乡重新开始。凯西发现了这件事并找到格温，要求她回家。争吵过后，格温同意了。凯西把她带到卧室，两人发生了性关系。正如《永远和五天》（Forever and Five Days）中所述，当格温躺在床上时，凯西拿出了她从阿尔派恩庄园带走的一些束缚带。她把格温的手腕绑在床上，然后走到床尾。
In her hands was a loaded gun that belonged to Gwen. Kathy inserted the gun barrel into Gwen's body, threatening, I'll kill you. Kathy left Gwen tied up for three hours. When she returned, Kathy removed it the gun and untied her. After a discussion, Kathy agreed it was over between them. Gwen returned to her girlfriend Heather. She asked why Gwen dropped everything to please Kathy. Gwen responded,
她手里拿着一把属于格温的装满子弹的手枪。凯西把枪管插进格温的身体，威胁说：“我会杀了你。”凯西把格温绑着留了三个小时。当她回来时，凯西拿走了枪并解开了她。经过一番讨论，凯西同意她们之间结束了。格温回到了她的女友希瑟身边。有人问为什么格温为了取悦凯西而放弃了一切。格温回答说：
Kathy has something over me. Gwen and Heather decided now was the time to act. In August 1987, they packed their belongings into Gwen's car and fled for Texas. With nowhere else to turn, Kathy Wood returned to her ex-husband, Ken. She told him she and Gwen had done things she was afraid of. She wanted to tell Ken, but he had to promise her first that he would keep it secret. He gave her his word. After a moment's silence, Kathy said to him, what's the worst thing you could think of to do to someone? Ken replied, murder would be the worst thing you could think of to do to someone. Can replied, murder would be the worst. Thinking there was no way Kathy would murder someone, he was completely taken aback when
“凯西抓住了我的把柄。”格温和希瑟决定现在是采取行动的时候了。1987年8月，她们把行李装进格温的车里，逃往德克萨斯州。走投无路的凯西·伍德回到了她的前夫肯身边。她告诉他，她和格温做了一些让她感到害怕的事情。她想告诉肯，但他必须先答应她保密。他给了她承诺。沉默片刻后，凯西对他说：“你能想到的对别人做的最坏的事情是什么？”肯回答说：“谋杀是你能想到的对别人做的最坏的事情。”肯回答说：“谋杀是最坏的。”他以为凯西绝不可能谋杀任何人，当她回答时，他完全惊呆了。
she replied. Well, try six times. Kathy told Ken about one of the residents they had killed, 97-year-old Edith Cook. Edith was one of the most popular residents among staff and other residents at Alpine Manor. She had been there for six years, once telling a social worker that Alpine Manor is grand, everything is all very lovely. She spent her days visiting and chatting to other residents, but in the months before her death, Edith's health deteriorated rapidly.
她说：“好吧，试试六次。”凯西告诉肯她们杀害的其中一位住户，97岁的伊迪丝·库克。伊迪丝是阿尔派恩庄园员工和其他住户中最受欢迎的人之一。她已经在那里住了六年，曾告诉一位社会工作者，阿尔派恩庄园很棒，一切都非常可爱。她每天都在探望和与其他住户聊天，但在她去世前的几个月里，伊迪丝的健康状况迅速恶化。
One night, she was found with her legs poking through the metal bars on her bed. Pressure saws developed which turned into painful gangrene. Edith's condition was deemed to be palliative, meaning that she would not survive. At 2.30 on the morning of Thursday, April 7, 1987, Edith Cook was found deceased in her bed. The night nurse assigned to her care was Kathy Wood. Also working on the wing that night was Gwen Graham. In an effort to understand what his ex-wife had just confessed, Ken asked if Kathy and Gwen killed people to end their pain and suffering.
一天晚上，人们发现她的双腿从床上的金属栏杆中伸了出来。压疮发展成了痛苦的坏疽。伊迪丝的情况被认为是姑息治疗，这意味着她无法存活。1987年4月7日星期四凌晨2点30分，伊迪丝·库克被发现死在床上。负责照顾她的夜班护士是凯西·伍德。当晚在同一病区工作的还有格温·格雷厄姆。为了理解前妻刚才的供述，肯问凯西和格温杀人是否是为了结束她们的痛苦和折磨。
Kathy replied, no, we did it for fun. Kathy went on to detail her experiences. The idea to murder residents at our Pine Manor arose one day, his shent Gwan sat at their dining table doing the morning crossword puzzle. Work had been getting boring and the pair had always wondered what it would be like to kill. They chose 60-year-old Marguerite chambers to be their first victim. On the night of Sunday January 18, 1987, after Marguerite's husband left for the night.
凯西回答说：“不，我们是为了好玩。”凯西接着详细讲述了她的经历。在阿尔派恩庄园谋杀住户的想法源于有一天，当她和格温坐在餐桌旁做晨间填字游戏时。工作变得很无聊，两人一直想知道杀人会是什么感觉。她们选择了60岁的玛格丽特·钱伯斯作为她们的第一个受害者。1987年1月18日星期日晚上，在玛格丽特的丈夫离开后。
Kathy said she and Gwen approached her room. Keeping watch by the door, Kathy made sure the coast was clear as Gwen slipped inside. She held two washcloths rolled into log shapes. Kathy claimed that Gwen took one washcloth and positioned it under Margaret's chin to support her jaw. She placed the other washcloth over Margaret's nose. Then she squeezed hard. Margaret thrashed in bed trying to free herself, but Gwen easily overpowered the ailing woman. Marguerite then went limp. Gwen slipped out without drawing attention from anyone else and walked back to her assigned wing.
凯西说她和格温走近了她的房间。凯西在门口放哨，确保周围安全，格温溜了进去。她拿着两条卷成圆木形状的毛巾。凯西声称格温拿了一条毛巾放在玛格丽特的下巴下支撑她的下颚。她把另一条毛巾放在玛格丽特的鼻子上。然后她用力挤压。玛格丽特在床上挣扎着想要挣脱，但格温轻易地制服了这位虚弱的妇女。玛格丽特随后瘫软了。格温没有引起任何人的注意就溜了出来，走回了她负责的病区。
Both she and Kathy were tending to other residents when Marguerite was found deceased less than 30 minutes later. This was not the first time Kathy and Gwen had tried to kill Marguerite. They had attempted the same method a month prior. Kathy explained that it had all gone to plan. They waited for the nursing aid assigned to Marguerite's care to find her dead. But Gwen had only rendered Marguerite unconscious. From this failed experience, Gwen learned she needed to suffocate her victim for a few
不到30分钟后，当玛格丽特被发现死亡时，她和凯西都在照顾其他住户。这不是凯西和格温第一次试图杀害玛格丽特。她们一个月前曾尝试过同样的方法。凯西解释说一切都按计划进行了。她们等着负责照顾玛格丽特的护理助理发现她死亡。但格温当时只让玛格丽特昏迷了过去。从这次失败的经历中，格温学到她需要在受害者停止移动后继续闷死她们几分钟。
minutes after they stopped moving. This attempted murder explained why Marguerite chambers had been so terrified of having her face cleaned with a washcloth. Kathy gave a strange explanation as to why they targeted Muggeri chambers first. At Alpine Manor there was a log book. Every time a resident passed away, their name was entered into the book with one entry per line. Muggeri started with the letter M. If they could find another five residents to kill with the initials they were looking for, then running down the page, they could spell out the word murder. But their plan was too hard. The residents they needed to make the murder
这次谋杀未遂解释了为什么玛格丽特·钱伯斯如此害怕用毛巾擦脸。凯西对她们为什么首先针对玛格丽特·钱伯斯给出了一个奇怪的解释。在阿尔派恩庄园有一本日志。每当一位住户去世，他们的名字就会被记入书中，一行一个名字。玛格丽特的名字以字母M开头。如果她们能找到另外五个名字首字母符合她们要求的住户来杀害，那么顺着页面往下看，她们就能拼出“谋杀”（MURDER）这个词。但她们的计划太难了。她们需要用来拼出“谋杀”首字母缩写的住户都是活跃且神志清醒的。相反，这对情侣选择了那些没有语言能力或患有晚期痴呆症的受害者。这样，即使她们在窒息中幸存下来，她们也无法告诉任何人。即使她们说了，也没人会相信她们。凯西和格温在住户躺在床上时捏住她们的鼻子，看看她们对空气供应突然被切断会有什么反应。如果有人反抗太激烈，两人就会转向其他人。这就是为什么有些住户被发现有无法解释的淤青或流鼻血。当需要实施杀戮时，格温使用毛巾以防止任何可能引起怀疑的淤青。
acronym were active and delusored. Instead, the couple chose victims who were non-verbal or suffering advanced dementia. That way, if they survived the suffocation, they would not be able to tell anyone. Even if they did, no one would believe them. Cathy and Gwen pinched residence noses while they lay in bed to see how they would react to having their air supply cut off suddenly. If one put up too much of a fight, the pair moved on to someone else. This was why some residents were found with unexplained bruising or bloody noses. When it was time to carry out the killings, Gwen used washcloths to prevent any bruising
（注：原文第67段与第66段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）根据凯西的说法，格温说她在杀人后感到更放松，说这有助于缓解她的紧张情绪。凯西和格温相信，分享谋杀的秘密会永远将她们捆绑在一起。肯对如何处理凯西提供的信息感到挣扎。他想相信这是一个编造的故事，但他不想完全不予理会。一年多过去了，肯为该怎么做而痛苦不堪。
that could raise suspicion. According to Cathy, Gwen said she felt more relaxed after killing someone, saying it helped to ease her tension. Cathy and Gwen believed that sharing the secret of the murders would bind them together forever. Ken struggled with what to do with the information Kathy had given him. He wanted to believe it was a fabricated story, but he didn't want to dismiss it entirely. Over a year past as Ken agonized over what to do.
（注：原文第68段与第67段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）在此期间，他把凯西的供述藏在心里，而她继续在阿尔派恩庄园工作。1988年10月6日星期四，肯开车经过警察局时，做出了一个临时的决定。他走进警察局报告了凯西的指控。当被问及为什么这么久才站出来时，肯解释说：“我不想毁掉我的生活，我也不想通过举报她来毁掉她的生活，但我觉得我应该查清楚凯西是否危险。我知道她恨起人来不输给任何人。”
During this time, he kept Kathy's confession to himself as she continued to work at our pint manner. On Thursday October 6, 1988, Ken was driving past the police station when he made a last minute decision. He went inside to report Kathy's allegations, when asked why he had waited so long to come forward, can explain. I didn't want to destroy my life and I didn't want to destroy her life by turning her in, but I felt I should find out if Kathy was dangerous. I know she can hate with the best of them.
（注：原文第69段与第68段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）第二天，凯西·伍德正在上班时，一名侦探来到了阿尔派恩庄园。他发现凯西在走廊里徘徊，告诉她他要带她去接受审讯。凯西表现得很惊讶，问为什么。她抓起外套，默默地陪同侦探离开。凯西同意接受采访。当被告知她的前夫指控她和格温·格雷厄姆谋杀了一名阿尔派恩庄园的住户时，凯西向后仰头大笑。侦探告诉她，他认为这并不好笑，这促使凯西冷静了下来。凯西对侦探们知无不言。虽然她告诉肯有六名受害者，但她告诉警方有五名。
The following day, Kathy Wood was at work when a detective arrived at our Pine Manor. He found Kathy wandering the hall and told her he was taking her in for questioning. Kathy did an act surprised or asked why. She grabs her coat and accompanied the detective in silence. Kathy agreed to be interviewed. When told that her ex-husband had implicated her and Gwen Graham in the murder of an out-planned man a resident, Kathy threw her head back and laughed. The detective told her he didn't think it was very funny, prompting Kathy to sober up. told her he didn't think it was very funny, prompting Kathy to sober up. Kathy was an open book to detectives. Although she'd told Ken there were six victims, she told police of five.
（注：原文第70段与第69段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）玛格丽特·钱伯斯、梅·梅森、贝尔·伯克哈德、伊迪丝·库克和默特尔·卢斯。可能还有另外三个是格温杀的，但凯西坚持说她记不清细节，或者她们被杀时她不在工作。她将策划犯罪描述为“某种程度上几乎令人兴奋”。凯西回忆起格温谋杀79岁的梅·梅森的那天晚上。格温走近凯西，告诉她她要对梅下手。凯西警告她现在不是时候。附近有两名护士，而且凯西被分配到了不同的病区。
Muggery chambers, main mason, bell-burkhard, Edith Cook, and Mertle loose. There might have been another three that Gwen killed, but Kathy maintained that she couldn't remember the details, or wasn't at work when they were killed. She described planning to crime-spray as, quote, almost exciting in a way. Kathy recalled the night Gwen murdered a 79-year-old Mae Mason. Gwen approached Kathy and told her she was going to do Mae. Kathy warned her it was not the right time. There were two nurses nearby and Kathy was assigned to a different wing.
（注：原文第71段与第70段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）但她们想出了一个计划。凯西用闲聊分散了护士们的注意力，而格温溜进了梅的卧室。当格温杀害贝尔·伯克哈德时，她们差点被发现。那天早上，凯西主动提出在其他员工休息时监督护士站。当她独自坐着时，格温从她被分配的病区走了过来。她的后口袋里有两条毛巾。凯西描述了格温是如何进入贝尔·伯克哈德的房间，而凯西则在护士站从前面放哨的。
But they came up with a plan. Kathy distracted the nurses with gossip while Gwen slipped into Mae's bedroom. They were very nearly discovered when Gwen killed Belle Berkard. That morning, Cathe had volunteered to supervise the nurses station while the other staff went on a break. As she sat alone, Gwen approached from the wing she was assigned to. In her back pocket were two washcloths. Kathy described how Gwann went into Bell Burkard's room while Kathy kept an eye out front from the nurse's station.
（注：原文第72段与第71段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）一个对讲机从贝尔的房间连到护士站。凯西能听到床单的沙沙声，然后是呻吟声。几分钟内，对讲机里传出了咕噜声，然后停止了。片刻之后，格温从房间里出现。几个小时后，一名护理助理发现贝尔已经死亡，她的手臂以一种奇怪的角度放在身体下方，皮肤上有严重的淤青。根据凯西的说法，格温说贝尔进行了激烈的反抗。她手臂上的淤青是格温跪在上面压制她造成的。在警察审讯期间，凯西被问及是什么促使格温谋杀？她回答说：“格温喜欢痛苦和痛苦的事情。”
An intercom ran from Bell's room to the station. Kathy could hear a rustle of sheets and then groaning noises. For a few minutes, gurgling noises sounded over the intercom, and then stopped. Moments later, Gwen appeared from the room. Belle was discovered deceased by a nursing aide a few hours later, with her arm positioned at an odd angle underneath her body, and severe bruising to the skin. According to Cathy, Gwen said that Belle had put up a tremendous fight. The bruising on her arm had been caused by Gwen kneeling on it to keep her still. During her police interview, Cathy was asked what would motivate Gwen to murder? She replied, Gwen liked pain and painful things.
（注：原文第73段与第72段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）“她的生活中有很多痛苦。我不知道她是否希望其他人也有同样的感受。”凯西说她在谋杀中的角色结束了，因为她厌倦了，不想再当望风的人了。她从未告诉格温停止，因为她希望她快乐。尽管如此，没有再发生杀戮。这两个女人最初计划轮流杀人，但凯西说她永远无法让自己成为杀手。
She had a lot of pain in her life. I don't know if she wanted other people to feel the same. Kathy said her role in the murders ended because she grew tired of it and didn't want to be a look out anymore. She never told Gwen to stop because she wanted her to be happy. Still, no further killings took place. The women had originally planned to take it in turns to kill, but Kathy said she could never bring herself to be the murderer.
（注：原文第74段与第73段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）她解释说：“那里的人对我来说就像家人一样，我不能对他们那样做。”凯西断言格温保留了每一位受害者的纪念品。从默特尔·卢斯那里，她拿走了一只袜子；从贝尔·伯克哈德那里，她拿走了一件首饰；从伊迪丝·库克那里，她拿走了一只耳环；从梅·梅森那里，她拿走了一个钥匙扣饰品。从玛格丽特·钱伯斯那里，她拿走了一个气球，那是她孩子们送给她的花束里带的。格温把它们放在浴室的一个鞋盒里，但有一个问题。
She explained, Those people in there were like family to me, and I couldn't do that to them. Kathy asserted that Gwen had kept a memento of every victim. From Mertle loose, she took a sock, from Bell Burkard, she took a jewelry, from Edith Cook and Earing, and from May Mason a keyring trinkered. From Marguerite Chambers, she took a balloon given to her with a bunch of flowers from her children. Gwen kept them in a shoebox in the bathroom, but there was a problem.
（注：原文第75段与第74段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）凯西解释说，当格温搬走时，她把那个盒子扔掉了。警方突击搜查了凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆一起工作期间有关住户死亡的阿尔派恩庄园档案。高层管理人员对谋杀调查表现出很少的关心。阿尔派恩庄园刚刚从认证该疗养院享受医疗补助的政府机构那里获得了极高的评价。在搜查过程中，侦探们发现了一封凯西写的信。信中部分写道：“我爱你，格温，我觉得你很棒。今天下午，我等不及了。”
Kathy explained to that when Gwen moved out, she had thrown the box away. Police raided the up-eyed mana files pertaining to resident deaths at the time Kathy would and Gwen Graham worked together. Upper management showed little concern about the murder investigation. Alpine Manor had just received a glowing review from the government body that certified the nursing home for Medicaid. During their search, detectives uncovered a letter Kathy had written. It read in part. I love you Gwen, I think you're great. For this afternoon, I cannot wait.
（注：原文第76段与第75段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）“那时我们会醒来，那时我会吻你。那时我会拥抱你。哦，格温，我想你。像兔子一样跳过来，让我舔你的耳朵。哦，请说你愿意成为我的。永远和五天。”侦探问凯西她诗中的最后一行是什么意思。她解释说，这是她们对莎士比亚名句“永远和一天”（forever and a day）的改编。
That's when we'll wake up and that's when I'll kiss you. That's when I'll hold you. Oh Gwen, I miss you. Bunny hop over here and let me lick you on the ear. Oh please say you'll be mine. Forever and five days. Detectives ask Kathy what the last line of her poem meant. She explained that it was their take on the Shakespearean line forever and a day.
（注：原文第77段与第76段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）每当她们杀害一名住户，凯西和格温就会在那句话上增加一天。在凯西的前夫首次接触警方六天后，警察到达了格温·格雷厄姆在德克萨斯州的拖车，她和女友希瑟在那里开始了新的生活。由于还没有发现谋杀的具体证据，警方以三年前开空头支票为由逮捕了格温。他们希望她在县监狱里可能会开口。相反，格温坚称自己无罪。她非常确定自己与阿尔派恩庄园的死亡事件无关，以至于她主动提出接受测谎仪测试。
Every time they killed a resident, Kathy and Gwen added an extra day to the saying. Six days after Kathy's ex-husband first approached police, officers arrived at Gwen Graham's trailer in Texas, where she'd started a new life with girlfriend Heather. With no concrete evidence of murder having been uncovered yet, police arrested Gwen for writing bad checks three years earlier. They hoped that she might open up while sitting in the county jail. Instead, Gwen protested her innocence. She was so certain that she had nothing to do with the deaths at our Pine Manna that she offered to take a polygraph test.
（注：原文第78段与第77段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）操作员告诉该案的首席侦探，在他看来，格温是一个冷血杀手，但测试结果是不确定的。格温·格雷厄姆被释放了。她回到了她在德克萨斯州一家医院担任护理助理的新工作。凯西·伍德也接受了测谎仪测试。作为她的第一个基准问题之一，凯西被问及她一生中发生过的最好的事情是什么。她回答说是她的女儿。然后她改变了主意，说是格温。至于最坏的事情，凯西立即说是格温离开她的时候。
The operator told the lead detective on the case that in his mind, Gwen was a cold-blooded killer, but the results of the test were inconclusive. Gwen Graham was free to go. She went back to her new job as a nursing aid for a Texas hospital. Kathy Ward also took a polygraph test. As one of her first baseline questions, Kathy was asked what the best thing that ever happened to her was. She replied that it was her daughter. Then she changed her mind and said Gwen. As for the worst thing, Cathy immediately said that it was when Gwen left her.
（注：原文第79段与第78段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）然后她被问到：“你在关于格温的事情上撒谎是为了让她惹上麻烦吗？”两个小时后，测谎仪检查员几乎可以肯定凯西是在试图操纵测试。她是在“玩一场微妙、聪明的游戏”。他认为格温·格雷厄姆没有杀任何人。这一切都是凯西策划的诡计，是格温离开她后的终极报复。在后续的测谎仪测试中，凯西被问及为什么有人会编造这样的故事。
She was then asked, Are you lying about Gwen to get her in trouble? After two hours, the polygraph examiner was left with little doubt that Cathy was trying to manipulate the test. She was, quote, playing a subtle, intelligent game. He believed that Gwen Graham hadn't killed anyone. It was all a ploy mastered by Cathy, the ultimate revenge for Gwen leaving her. In a follow-up polygraph test, Kathy was asked why someone would make up a story like this.
（注：原文第80段与第79段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）她回答说：“他们一定非常不快乐，非常孤独。也许他们甚至像我一样想坐牢，因为那样他们就不必担心任何事情了。”随着阿尔派恩庄园谋杀案调查进入第六周，一台挖掘机被带到了罗斯代尔纪念公墓。决定已经做出，要挖掘玛格丽特·钱伯斯和伊迪丝·库克的遗体。
She replied, they'd have to be awfully unhappy, awfully lonely. Maybe they even want to go to prison like I do, because then they won't have to worry about anything. As the up-hired man and murders investigation reached its sixth week, an excavator was brought to the Rosedale Memorial Cemetery. The decision had been made to excavate the remains of Marguerite Chambers and Edith Cork.
（注：原文第81段与第80段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）凯西·伍德列出的其他所有受害者都已被火化。玛格丽特的丈夫埃德批准了挖掘。他被她可能被谋杀的现实所困扰，告诉美联社：“我经历过一次玛格丽特的死亡。我不想再经历第二次。”自从所谓谋杀案的消息传出以来，他每晚都做噩梦，梦见自己在睡梦中被闷死。水渗进了玛格丽特的棺材，由于腐烂，对她身体的检查变得困难。玛格丽特和伊迪丝的口腔都经过了检查，法医希望找到毛巾纤维来支持凯西的谋杀理论。他还检查了她们脸上的皮肤是否有擦伤，并检查了她们的眼睑，寻找可能表明窒息的针尖状淤青。没有发现纤维或窒息迹象。
Every other victim listed by Kathy Wood had been cremated. Marguerite's husband Ed had given the go-ahead. He was haunted by the realization that she might have been murdered, telling the associated press. I went through Marguerite's death once. I don't want to go through it twice. Since news of the alleged murder, he had suffered nightmares every night about being suffocated in his sleep. Water had leaked inside Margarete's coffin, making an examination of her body difficult due to decomposition. Both Margarete's and Edeth's mouths were checked, with the medical examiner hoping to find fibres of washcloths to support Cathy's murder theory. He also checked the skin on their faces for abrasions and checked their eyelids, looking for pimpriarchized bruises that can indicate suffocation. No fibers or signs of suffocation were found.
（注：原文第82段与第81段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）凯西声称，当格温杀害伊迪丝·库克时，她说她犯了一个错误，因为她在伊迪丝还戴着假牙的情况下闷死了她。如果属实，检查将显示伊迪丝口腔有擦伤，表明她在被闷死时咬紧了牙关。但那里没有。玛格丽特和伊迪丝的死因被列为心脏病发作。当病理学家检查她们的心脏时，他确定了一件事。她们的心脏状况良好，她们不是死于心脏病发作。
Cathy claimed that when Gwen killed Edith Cook she said she had made a mistake by suffocating her with her false teeth still in. If true, the examination would show abrasions to Edith's mouth indicating that she had bitten down while being suffocated. They weren't there. Mugareed and Edith's cause of death were listed as heart attacks. When the pathologist examined their hearts, he was certain of one thing. Their hearts were in good condition, and they had not died from a heart attack. Their hearts were in good condition and they had not died from a heart attack.
（注：原文第83段与第82段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）基于这些发现和凯西·伍德提供的间接证据，法医将她们的死因从心脏病发作改为他杀。1988年12月4日星期日，侦探们手持逮捕令包围了格温·格雷厄姆在德克萨斯州的家。里面的灯亮着，但敲前门无人应答。拖车公园经理透露，格温和她的女友几周前就逃走了。他不知道她们去了哪里。侦探们回到车里，当他们驶向十字路口时，一辆野马车开了过去。
Based on these findings and the circumstantial evidence provided by Cathy Wood, the medical examiner changed their cause of death from heart attack to homicide. On Sunday, December 4, 1988, detectives surrounded Gwen Graham's home in Texas with an arrest warrant in hand. The lights were on inside, but Knox to the front door went unanswered. The trailer park manager revealed that Gwen and her girlfriend had fled weeks ago. He had no idea where they went. Detectives returned to their vehicles and as they pulled up to an intersection, a Mustang drove by.
（注：原文第84段与第83段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）驾驶座上是格温·格雷厄姆。她迅速被捕，没有发生意外，并被处以一百万美元的保释金。凯西·伍德几小时后被捕。阿尔·范戴克正坐在家里，接到了一个代表阿尔派恩庄园打来的电话。打电话的人读了一份预先写好的声明，解释说他打电话的目的是
Behind the wheel was Gwann Graham. She was swiftly arrested without incident and held on a million dollar bond. Cathy Wood was arrested a few hours later. Al Vant Dyke was sitting at home when he received a telephone call on behalf of our fine manner. Reading from a pre-written statement, the caller explained that the purpose of his call
（注：原文第85段与第84段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）通知阿尔，他的母亲露丝·范戴克可能是该疗养院发生的一系列所谓他杀案件的受害者。阿尔不敢相信。他自己曾是一名他杀案侦探。另一个电话打给了唐·阿尔多·班斯基，他是90岁的万达的侄子和法定监护人。在被告知万达死于肺炎后，唐说，意识到他的姑姑可能被谋杀，这让他感到如遭雷击。
was to notify Al that his mother, Ruth Vant Dyke, was a possible victim in a series of alleged homicides that happened at the nursing home. Al couldn't believe it. He was a former homicide detective himself. Another call went to Don Aldo Banski, the nephew and the legal guardian of 90-year-old Wanda. Having been told that Wanda had died from pneumonia, Donor said the realization that his aunt could have been murdered hit him like a bolt of lightning.
（注：原文第86段与第85段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）他回想起她在阿尔派恩庄园的最后几个月，有些事情开始变得合理了。工作人员经常联系他，告知万达身上有淤青、擦伤和撕裂伤。他一直想知道为什么。万达根本无法移动。阿尔派恩庄园的代表那天又打了五个电话。总共，凯西在与侦探的采访中点名了八名她认为被谋杀的住户。然而，贝尔·伯克哈德的女儿南希·哈恩是从一位给她家打电话的记者那里得知的。当她第二天早上打电话给阿尔派恩庄园询问为什么没有通知她时，经理回答说：
He thought back to her last month's in-appine manner and something began to make sense. Staff were regularly contacting him to advise that Wanda had sustained bruising abrasions and elacerations. He had always wondered why. Wanda couldn't move. The representative from our plan manner made another five calls that day. In total, Kathy had named eight residents in her interviews with detectives that she believed had been murdered. However, Bell Burkard's daughter, Nancy Hahn, found out from a journalist who called at her home. When she rang Alpine Manor the following morning to find out why she hadn't been notified. The manager replied,
（注：原文第87段与第86段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）“我很抱歉，这是一个疏忽。”1988年1月，密歇根州卫生部进行了自己的调查。调查发现，阿尔派恩庄园的管理层行为得当，没有理由怀疑在谋杀发生时存在任何虐待老人的行为。随着他杀案的消息传出，护理人员被命令不得与媒体交谈。一位经理确实告诉记者：“凯西·伍德的评价非常好。”
I'm sorry, it was an oversight. In January 1988, the Michigan Health Department conducted its own investigation. It found that Alpine Manor management had acted appropriately and had no reason to suspect that there was any elder abuse going on at the time of the murders. As news of the homicide's broke, nursing staff were ordered not to speak to the press. One manager did tell reporters, Kathy Woods' reviews were great.
（注：原文第88段与第87段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）“你找不到比她更专业的人了。凯西非常受欢迎。她是大家的最爱。”检察官面临一个问题。只有足够的证据起诉格温·格雷厄姆谋杀玛格丽特·钱伯斯和伊迪丝·库克，即遗体被挖掘出来的两名妇女。即便如此，案件在很大程度上依赖于凯西·伍德的证词。没有她的配合，案件就会崩溃。因此，检方为凯西提供了一项认罪协议，以换取她在审判中的证词。如果凯西承认二级谋杀罪和一项共谋谋杀罪，
You couldn't ask for anyone more professional. Kathy was very popular. she was a favorite. Prosecutors faced a problem. There was only enough evidence to charge Gwen Graham with the murders of Marguerite Chambers and Dieteth Cook, the two women whose bodies were exhumed. Even then, the case relied heavily on Cathy Woods' testimony. Without her cooperation, the case would fall apart. Because of this, the prosecution offered Cathy a plea deal in exchange for her testimony at trial. If Cathy pleaded guilty to second degree murder and one count of conspiracy to commit murder,
（注：原文第89段与第88段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）她将获得更轻的刑期，并有可能获得假释。凯西同意了，随之而来的是对格温的进一步指控。她现在被控共谋谋杀和一级谋杀阿尔派恩庄园的五名住户。格温的辩护团队几乎肯定她会被无罪释放。没有毛巾纤维或指纹将他们的当事人与受害者联系起来。凯西声称格温作为纪念品拿走的任何纪念品都没有被找到。与格温唯一的联系是凯西的话，他们说凯西有撒谎的动机。他们声称整个故事是凯西为了报复格温离开她而编造的。
she would be given a more lenient jail sentence with the possibility of parole. Kathy agreed, and with that, further charges were brought against Gwen. She was now charged with conspiracy to commit murder and the first-degree murder of five residents from our Pine Manor. Guan's defense team were almost certain she would be acquitted. There were no washcloth fibres or fingerprints linking their client to the victims. None of the mementos that Kathy claimed Gwen had taken as souvenirs had been found. The only link to Gwen was Kathy's word, who they said had a motive for lying. They alleged that the entire story was concocted by Kathy to get back at Gwen for leaving
（注：原文第90段与第89段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）这是一个得到格温许多朋友和同事支持的指控，他们根本不相信格温会犯下谋杀罪。然而，格温和凯西曾向至少另外三名护理助理和凯西的姐姐承认她们参与了谋杀阿尔派恩庄园的住户。他们中没有人相信她们是认真的。审判于1989年9月开始。在开庭陈述中，助理检察官警告陪审团：“这是一个离奇的案件，是由离奇的人犯下的。”凯西针对格温作证了整整两天。
her. It was an allegation supported by many of Gwen's friends and co-workers who couldn't believe for a second that Gwen was guilty of murder. Yet, Gwen and Kathy had confessed to their involvement in murdering Alpine Manor residents to at least three other nursing aids and to Kathy's sister. None of them believed they were being serious. The trial began in September 1989. In his opening statements, the assistant prosecutor warned the jury that, this is a bizarre case and it was committed by bizarre people. and it was committed by bizarre people. Kathy testified against Gwen for two full days.
（注：原文第91段与第90段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）她显得泪流满面，说话轻声细语，详细描述了她是如何在格温闷死阿尔派恩庄园的受害者时站在一旁望风的。她向陪审团表示，她自己也是格温的受害者，作证说她是被绑在床上并被枪插入阴道的那个人。检方还有最后一名证人要传唤。那是格温的女友希瑟，她证实她和格温不再是情侣了。希瑟告诉法庭警方第一次来到拖车搜查的那天。
Appearing tearful and softly spoken, she detailed how she stood to look out while Gwen suffocated the victims of our pine manner. She appeared to the jury that she herself was a victim of Gwen's, testifying that she was the one who had been tied to their bed with a gun inserted in her vagina. The prosecution had one final witness to call. It was Gwant's girlfriend Heather, who confirmed that she and Gwant were no longer a couple. Heather told the courtroom about the day police had first come to the trailer to search.
（注：原文第92段与第91段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）在他们离开后，希瑟问她是否谋杀了阿尔派恩庄园的住户。格温回答说：“是的。”希瑟不想相信，回答说：“不，你没有。”希瑟向陪审团展示了格温是如何抓住她的肩膀摇晃她，说：“我知道你不想相信，但我确实做了。我做了。”当希瑟走下证人席并被护送离开时，格温大喊：“我仍然爱你，希瑟。”陪审团审议了六个小时。
After they visited, Heather asked if she had murdered residents of our plan manner. Gwen replied, yes. Not wanting to believe it, Heather replied, no you didn't. Heather showed the jury how Gwen had shaken her by the shoulders, saying, I know you don't want to believe it, but I did it. I did. As Heather stepped down from the witness box and was escorted away, Gwen shouted, I still love you, Heather. The jury deliberated for six hours.
（注：原文第93段与第92段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）因一级谋杀五名受害者和共谋谋杀罪，格温·格雷厄姆被判有罪。当判决宣读时，格温没有表现出任何情绪。她被判处终身监禁，不得假释。受害者的家属挤满了法庭外的台阶。他们对判决感到集体高兴，尽管玛格丽特·钱伯斯的丈夫埃德告诉记者，他希望密歇根州仍然保留死刑。他的女儿简说：“我的母亲终于可以安息了。伤疤将永远存在，但知道真相会有所帮助。”
For the first degree murder of five victims and the charge of conspiracy to commit murder, Gwen Graham was found guilty. Gwen showed no emotion as the verdicts were read. She was sentenced to life in prison with no possibility of parole. Families of the victims crowded the steps outside the courtroom. They were collectively happy with the verdict, although Muggery Chamber's husband Ed told reporters he wished Michigan still had the death penalty in place. His daughter, Jan, said, My mother can finally rest in peace. The scars will always be there, but it helps knowing
（注：原文第94段与第93段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）审判中一个明显的缺席者是默特尔·卢斯的女儿黑泽尔·德拉格。黑泽尔在默特尔活着的时候一直是她生活中的常客。她几乎每天都去阿尔派恩庄园，确保她的母亲得到照顾。但像她的母亲一样，黑泽尔也患上了阿尔茨海默病。审判时，她是阿尔派恩庄园的住户。审判后，阿尔派恩庄园向媒体发表了一份声明，写道：“尽管我们觉得很难相信这一切真的发生了，但我们的首要目标是帮助住户及其家人的福祉。我们将继续在我们的疗养院提供支持性环境中的优质护理。”
the truth. One noticeable absence at the trial was Hazel Drage, the daughter of Murdered Evictum, Mertel Luce. Hazel had been a constant presence in Mertel's life while she was alive. She visited Alpine Manor almost daily to make sure her mother was being cared for. But like her mother, Haisal had succumbed to Alzheimer's disease. At the time of the trial, she was a resident at Alpine Manor. Following the trial, Alpine Manor released a statement to the media which read, even though we find it difficult to believe that any of this actually happened, our primary goal is to help the well-being of residents and their families. We will continue to provide quality care in a supportive environment in our nursing home.
（注：原文第95段与第94段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）1989年10月，凯西·伍德被判刑。她的律师宣读了一份声明，称：“说对不起是不够的。言语无法表达我余生将不得不带着的悔恨或内疚。”在宣判前，法官评论道：“我印象最深的是，如果不是你站出来，我相信这件事永远不会被查清。如果我今天放了你，我确信你不会再做这样的事了。”凯西·伍德被判处20至40年监禁。表现良好，她服刑16年后就有资格获得假释。许多人认为凯西在谋杀案中的参与不仅仅是站在一旁望风。
In October 1989, Cathy Wood was sentenced. Her lawyer read from a statement which said, Saying I'm sorry is not enough. mere words cannot express the remorse or guilt I'll have to live with for the rest of my life. Before handing down his sentence, the judge remarked, I'm most impressed by the fact that if it wasn't for you coming forward, I'm sure this matter never would have been cleared up. If I turned you loose today, I'm convinced you wouldn't do anything like this again. Kathy Wood was sentenced to 20 to 40 years in prison. With good behavior, she would be eligible for parole after serving only 16. Many people believe that Kathy was more involved in the murders than simply standing look out.
（注：原文第96段与第95段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）护理人员记得她是一个操纵性的骗子，并确信她欺骗了所有人，从案件的侦探到审判法官。正如《永远和五天》一书中所述，一位名叫莫琳·哈弗希尔的理发师在1987年底正在为阿尔派恩庄园的住户露西尔·范德文理发。露西尔非常痛苦，告诉理发师：“他们昨晚试图杀我，他们试图在床上闷死我，但我反抗了，我挥动、踢打和抓挠，他们没能做到。”莫琳向露西尔保证没有人试图杀她，但在听说阿尔派恩庄园的谋杀案后，她意识到露西尔可能说的是实话。然而，攻击露西尔的不可能是格温·格雷厄姆。她五周前就离开了阿尔派恩庄园。凯西·伍德的一名狱友说她在监狱里吹嘘谋杀案，向其他囚犯展示关于此案的剪报。这名囚犯说，当她们讨论谋杀案时，凯西据称承认：“我做了那些谋杀，我真的报复了那个婊子。这就是格温和我分手应得的下场。”
Nursing staff remembered her as a manipulative liar and were convinced that she pulled the wool over everyone's eyes, from detectives on the case, to the trial judge. As detailed in the book Forever and Five Days, a hairdresser named Maureen Haverhill was tending to our Pymano resident Lucille Vendervine in late 1987. Lucille was very distressed and told the hairdresser, they tried to kill me last night, they tried to smother me in my bed, but I fought back, I swung and I kept and I scratched and they couldn't do it. Morena sure to Lucille that nobody was trying to kill her, but after hearing of the Alpine
（注：原文第97段与第96段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）2018年9月，凯西·伍德申请假释。她的申请遭到了阿尔派恩庄园受害者家属的挑战，他们提出了上诉。他们认为她没有表现出悔意，并且像案件中的大多数人一样，认为她在谋杀案中比她承认的更积极。他们还生活在凯西出狱后会追捕他们的恐惧中。梅·梅森的孙女特别强烈地谴责凯西的假释，她用枪和顶级的家庭安全系统武装了自己。尽管受害者家属提出了上诉，且公众舆论哗然，凯西·伍德仍被认为不再对社会构成威胁。57岁时，在服刑30年后，她被释放出狱，搬到南卡罗来纳州与她的姐姐住在一起。
Manor murders she realized that Lucille might have been telling the truth. Yet, it couldn't have been Gwen Graham who attacked Lucille. She had left our pie manner five weeks earlier. A former inmate of Kathy Woods said she bragged about the murders in prison, showing other inmates clippings from newspapers about the case. The inmate said that they were discussing the murders when Kathi allegedly admitted, I did the murders, I really got that bitch back. That's what Gwen gets for breaking up with me.
（注：原文第98段与第97段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）一位参与此案的退休侦探认为她不应该获得假释，他告诉当地新闻台WOOD TV：“我相信凯西·伍德是主谋。她是那个在格温·格雷厄姆背后操纵的人。出于安全考虑，我不希望我的孙子孙女或老年住户在她身边。她是一个连环杀手，她可能会再次作案，大多数连环杀手都会。”随着凯西·伍德的假释，此前未向公众公开的法庭文件被发布。
In September 2018, Kathi Wood came up for parole. Her application was challenged by family members of the victims of our pyamana, who filed an appeal. They believed she had shown no remorse and, like the majority of people involved in the case, believed that she was more active in the murders than she admitted. They also lived in fear that Kathy would hunt them down
（注：原文第99段与第98段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）第一次披露，在某个阶段，凯西和格温因阿尔派恩庄园总共12起死亡事件而受到调查。然而，缺乏证据阻止了案件进入审判。多年来，凯西和格温赢得了“致命恋人”的绰号。审判一年后，阿尔派恩庄园被卖给了一个医院集团，该集团对疗养院进行了大规模翻新和品牌重塑。密歇根州的立法进行了审查，疗养院受到更严格条件的约束。在今天的密歇根州，疗养院中涉嫌虐待老人的行为必须报告给成人保护服务调查员。
when she was released from prison. May Mason's granddaughter, who was particularly vocal in her condemnation of Kathy's parole, armed herself with a gun and top of the line home security. Despite the appeal from the victim's families and considerable public outrage, Kathy would was deemed as no longer a threat to society. At 57 years of age, after serving a 30-year sentence, she was released from prison and moved to South Carolina to live with her sister.
（注：原文第100段与第99段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）疗养院仍然在与阿尔派恩庄园谋杀案发生时显而易见的同样问题作斗争。需要全职护理的老龄化人口、人手不足的劳动力以及过度劳累和薪酬过低的护士，是提供护理时面临的巨大挑战。密歇根州目前的立法规定，白天每八名住户需要一名认证护理助理。在晚上，一名认证护理助理可以合法地被分配照顾15名住户。凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆的动机究竟是什么，可能永远不会为人所知。一位代表另一名在肯塔基州和俄亥俄州二十年间谋杀数十名老年患者的护士的律师告诉《底特律自由报》：
A retired detective who worked on the case believed she shouldn't have been paroled, telling local news station would TV. I believe that Kathy Wood was the mastermind. She was the one that was pulling strings on Gwen Graham. For safety reasons, I wouldn't want my grandchildren or elderly residents around her. She's a serial killer and she could do it again, and most of them do. With Kathy Woods' parole came the release of court documents previously withheld from the public.
（注：原文第101段与第100段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）“通常犯下这些罪行的人是被社会拒绝或感到被拒绝的人。他们唯一能发泄的对象是那些比他们弱势的人，即他们照顾的人。”在凯西·伍德被判刑前，她的前夫肯写了一封信给法官。信中他说：“凯西有罪，因为她夺走了生命，或者至少没有阻止格温夺走生命。但她真的夺走了多少生命？所有的受害者甚至都没有在生活。他们享受不到任何东西，体验不到任何东西，而且终将死去。”这是当时大多数公众对谋杀案的看法。普遍的共识是，凯西和格温不应该因为她们的行为受到太严厉的判决，因为她们针对的是弱者和病者。这是一个让受害者家属感到崩溃的观点。受害者默特尔·卢斯的儿媳玛克辛·卢斯说，她们针对弱势群体是让她们的罪行特别令人憎恶的原因。“当我想到默特尔处于那种境地，有人故意切断她的呼吸时，那才是事情的可怕之处。当她们像孩子一样无助时。”玛格丽特·钱伯斯的女儿简·恩德曼告诉WOOD TV，她感到崩溃的是，她从未能与母亲告别。凯西和格温夺走了这一点。受害者梅·梅森的女婿约翰·恩格曼说：“梅不应该受到这种死亡方式。这些人都不应该。他们过着美好的生活，并期望人们会照顾他们，直到他们自然死亡。”
For the first time that was revealed that at one stage, Kathy and Gwen were under investigation for a total of 12 deaths at Alpine Manor. However, a lack of evidence prevented the cases from moving to trial. Over the years, Cathy and Gwen earned the moniker, the lethal lovers. A year after the trials, Alpine Manor was sold to a hospital group who extensively renovated and rebranded the nursing home. Legislation in Michigan was reviewed and nursing homes subject to more stringent conditions. In Michigan today, suspected order abuse in nursing homes must be reported to adult protective services investigators.
（注：原文第102段与第101段内容有重叠，此处按逻辑翻译）本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Nursing homes still struggle with the same problems evident at the time of the upper mana murders. An aging population requiring full-time care, and understaffed workforce, and overworked and underpaid nurses, are enormous challenges faced in providing care. Current legislation in Michigan dictates that only one certified nursing assistant be required for eight residents during the day. At night, one certified nursing assistant can legally be assigned 15 residents to care for. It will probably never be known exactly what motivated Kathy Wood and Gwen Graham. A lawyer who represented another nurse convicted of murdering dozens of elderly patients over the span of two decades in Kentucky and Ohio told the Detroit Free Press that,
疗养院至今仍面临着阿尔皮纳谋杀案发生时就已存在的同样问题。人口老龄化导致的全职护理需求、人手不足的员工队伍，以及过度劳累且薪酬过低的护士，都是提供护理服务时面临的巨大挑战。密歇根州现行法律规定，白天每八名住户只需配备一名认证护理助理。而在夜间，一名认证护理助理在法律上可以被分配照顾15名住户。凯西·伍德和格温·格雷厄姆的作案动机可能永远无法确切得知。一位曾为另一名护士辩护的律师告诉《底特律自由报》，该护士在肯塔基州和俄亥俄州二十年间杀害了数十名老年患者，他说，
the people that are commonly committing these crimes are those that are rejected by society or feel rejected. The only people they can lash out at are those less powerful than they are, the people they care for. Before Kathy Wood was sentenced, her ex-husband Ken wrote a letter to the judge. In it, he said. Kathy is guilty of taking lives, or at least not preventing Gwen from taking them. But how much life did she really take? All of the victims weren't even living. They enjoyed
通常犯下这些罪行的人是被社会排斥或感到被排斥的人。他们唯一能发泄的对象就是那些比他们更弱势的人，也就是他们所照顾的人。在凯西·伍德被判刑之前，她的前夫肯写了一封信给法官。信中他说，凯西确实犯下了夺取生命的罪行，或者至少没有阻止格温夺走生命。但她到底夺走了多少生命呢？所有的受害者甚至都已经没有生活质量了。他们享受
nothing, experienced nothing, and were going to die. This was the opinion voiced by the majority of the public at the time of the murders. The general consensus was that Kathi and Guan didn't deserve to be sentenced to harshly for their actions because they targeted the weak and sick. It was an opinion that devastated the victim's families. Maxine Luce, the daughter-in-law of victim Mertel Luce, said that their targeting of the vulnerable was what made their crimes particularly abhorrent. Quote, When I think of Mertel in that position and someone deliberately cutting off her breath,
不到任何东西，经历不到任何东西，而且终将死去。这是谋杀案发生时大多数公众表达的观点。普遍的共识是，凯西和格温不应因其行为受到过严的惩罚，因为她们针对的是弱者和病患。这种观点让受害者家属感到崩溃。受害者默特尔·卢斯的儿媳玛克辛·卢斯表示，她们针对弱势群体的行为使她们的罪行显得格外令人憎恶。她说：“当我想到默特尔处于那种境地，而有人故意切断她的呼吸时，
that's the horror of the thing. When they're so helpless, like children. Jain Enderman, Marguerite Chambers' daughter, said to Wood TV that she was devastated that she never got to say goodbye to her mother. Cathy and Gwan took that away from her. John Engman, son-in-law to victim May Mason, said, May did not deserve this sort of death. None of those people did. They lived good lives, and expected people would take care of them until they passed from natural causes. What is? you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那才是最恐怖的事情。当他们像孩子一样无助时。玛格丽特·钱伯斯的女儿简·恩德曼告诉伍德电视台，她感到非常痛苦，因为她从未能与母亲告别。凯西和格温夺走了这一切。受害者梅·梅森的女婿约翰·恩格曼说，梅不应该遭受这样的死亡。他们中没有一个人应该这样。他们过着美好的生活，并期望人们能照顾他们直到他们自然离世。这是什么？目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。